Summer travel is more popular than ever...
...and this list of our top locations might help you...
...get a head start on your summer preparations.
A summer trip to Tanzania will allow you to experience the safari season.
Tanzania defies categorization as the site of memorable Serengeti safaris...
...and tranquil immersion on Zanzibar's soft sand beaches,...
...offering insights into unique animals, vibrant birds and remarkable culture.
Cuban summers are authentic and vibrant.
The island is enveloped in tropical warmth punctuated by atmospheric seasonal rains...
...that assist to calm the days or create a sensuous soundtrack to the evening.
From Havana to Santiago,...
...the seasonal heat only fuels local fervor as music, art and a sense of community...
...erupt around every corner.
The remaining colonial architecture seeps with history and tradition shapes current culture.
Cuba is an intriguing summer getaway with its coral reefs,...
...gorgeous shoreline and a society eager  to enjoy.